oh you can knock out smooth the beat
most of the time but you can't knock out
the campaign I don't I'm so gone I'm
still going
no you're not no you're not Steve wake
up sir we're done was it successful
what's your definition of success
y-yeah forget red will you be able to
have an erection what what did you say
why able to I'd be able to get red all
right kurz yep
yeah man dandy dude [ __ ] thank you for
coming dude my pleasure besties my hero
man did have [ __ ] cool that was to
like have like a pet time we drive that
car around
did you get the percocet screwed I mean
we still didn't get picked up but so you
feel the catalyst I just took some Advil
it's working for your ass huh
somebody disconnected your pain fibers
yeah which is good I mean rather this
situation that's good okay so when did
you go be here ah 2009 at your labs
um I'm telling this be unbelievable God
if you ask me how many forty-year-old
people I see with loves like that wow
you got some railroad tracks here you've
got staples you see my man and we got to
take those out there's three screws
above and four below we used two screws
over there it's time for me to admit
that
idea was stupid as [ __ ] I was never
gonna get it and was never gonna stop
trying so it's still going strong and
just title on advil because [ __ ]
painkillers and exactly ten days I'm
going back on my ridiculous comedy tour
and after every single show I'm doing a
meet-and-greet where I'm going to meet
and take a photo with every single
person that wants one the first stop is
Maryland then Massachusetts Connecticut
Florida Wisconsin Washington State
Minnesota
Kentucky and then United Kingdom in
Europe I'm coming for you with the
entire television production crew it is
the end of the world tour and it is on